this is us you you play the mom to
triplets I do and so you're working with
kids all the time and this is something
I've noticed and I'm sure and even
though this is - when we work with kids
yeah on the set sometimes you kind of
become a little bit of a babysitter sure
because their parents you know they're
there but sometimes they're you know out
back having a drink
no but yeah and you can have to look
after them a little bit I played the mom
to triplets so we have three
extraordinary young actors on the show
who have fantastic parents by the way
and they're very attentive but I think
it's exciting it's a lot of their first
jobs a lot of for most of them and you
know anytime there's a scene that
requires them to eat I've had to remind
them my love alas my husband on the show
we're always like guys slow down because
you don't realize you're committing
yourself to eating that same amount for
the entirety of the scene which can
sometimes be a couple hours and I
remember we're shooting a Christmas
episode and there was some like melted
peppermints and like a candy dish that
wasn't even from the prop department
like clearly it was set decoration and I
turned my back for one second and I
turned back in all of them of like
jammed peppermints in their mouth I
don't know how old yeah back in the
morning
no sometimes when there's food on a set
yeah food is meant to look good on TV
and sometimes I've been on a set and
they've done the food so that it looks
really nice then you look up close and
it's like a wedding scene you look up
close to the food and you realize that
oh this is like coated in varnish it's
sweating yeah this was used like eight
years ago in a movie and they just hosed
it down with varnish so that could
always be used sure that never stops us
from eating it it's not the kids either
so yeah I would think that would be a
major problem because you've got to keep
an eye on them all the time
yeah they don't get a stomachache as
playing this character made you think at
all about like okay maybe I'd like to
have kids or is if you think the
opposite no I mean we get to hold these
like newborn children and I can't
believe their parents who are willing to
like hand over their babies to me and
the Khayyam Mandy had
absolutely no experience with small
children and they're like here here's my
two month old baby right I don't know
how to change a diaper I have the crew
member showing me how to like change it
I'm terrible but yes it has sort of like
activated that that maternal side of me
that I'm totally ready to have kids now
but the only thing is you're not having
the real experience you're having the
experience again the baby on the minute
there's a problem take it away
you're know you're really more ready to
be a grandmother yeah that is a very
good point yeah that grandma being a
grandparent is we don't have kids Andy
and I have kids together yeah it's the
most progressive show on television but
no we are you know we have kids and yeah
I but I see the grandparents come in I
go like that's the gig that's fantastic
they'll say like oh I just gave the kid
a banana split you know and and I'll say
don't do that they'll be up all night
they're like not my problem yeah yeah
he's getting fussy yeah yeah he's
getting slightly difficult you're a
problem now and then they jump out a
window to get away all right we're going
to talk more [ __ ] about kids in just a
second that's what we do here this is
the name of our new show talking [ __ ]
about kids
with the lovely Mandy Moore when we
return stick around
you